NATO an absolutely horrific story out of
Oklahoma's seven bodies discovered there
about an hour south of Tulsa we don't
have many more details than that but we
do know there is heartache here Omar via
Franca has more
we've searched the property and we've
located uh seven bodies Oklahoma law
enforcement found those bodies in
Henrietta Monday but would not discuss
any additional facts of the case there's
no suspect at large that we are looking
for right at this moment while neither a
motive nor the name of a suspect has
been released the father of 16 year old
Brittany Brewer confirmed his daughter
was among the dead she always played
with her little sister and and I don't
know how I'm gonna tell her because
she's like Britney's law Britney's
missing Britney's missing and I gotta
tell a four-year-old that she's gone and
I don't even know how to do that earlier
in the day Oklahoma Highway Patrol
reported Brewer was endangered and
missing along with her friend
fourteen-year-old Ivy Webster they were
believed to be traveling with 39 year
old Jesse McFadden Brewer's father told
Tulsa station KOTV that his daughter was
friends with McFadden's children and had
spent the weekend with the McFadden
family and was supposed to come home
Sunday night but never arrived
records from the State's Department of
Corrections showed that McFadden was
convicted on first-degree rape charges
in November of 2003 and released from
prison in October 2020.
he was slated to stand trial Monday on
charges of soliciting sexual conduct
with a minor and possession of child
pornography for CBS mornings I'm Omar
villafranca